I'm just trying to get the exposure
because it's like nobody knows who the
heck I am if I just lost my last deal I
need to make money then I'd be looking
at charging more and more Hands-On so
not just do the app and I'll check in on
you but like you're doing the workouts
with them you're watching them you're
giving them plans I could help any
entrepreneur I could say hey I'm going
to help you as an entrepreneur or I
could help you with your YouTube channel
right okay specific if you're just gonna
charge some executive to be a PT like
there's so many people who can do that
but if you're helping people get ready
for competition there's fewer people
doing it but fewer people who are
coaching as well who are the people who
are organizing the competitions who are
the people who maybe competed and lost
that then you can reach out to and say
hey I'm a trainer who specializes in
this I think you'll have a much better
result with that in terms of clients
than posting on Tick Tock like it's the
Outreach to build referrals again to get
you to the point where you're making a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
to feed you and everything else and then
worry about content and everything else
because you're in such a niche that
people respect and will pay for they
just need to know you exist
I would love to be the guy that was just
making a couple hundred bucks on my
entrepreneur thing I literally just lost
the last client I had uh on my personal
training thing and I guess but my
question is I'm just trying to get the
exposure because it's like nobody knows
who the heck I am I'm on Tick Tock I'm
on YouTube it seems like YouTube shorts
work pretty decent for me that's where I
end up getting more subscribers and
people actually watch the show and stuff
like that so
I don't know what what are some of the
new tech savvy ways to get me out there
a little bit better right you're just
trying to grow your personal training
business right and actually just I mean
get client it doesn't even give you
content it's more referrals can you
train anybody yeah I can train anybody
you know I mean or a person
uh it would be online it's a it's an
actual online app where I give you your
exercises and you know I'll do Zoom
meetings with the person to uh check up
on them and things like that but it's
more you know for anybody worldwide that
wants to get healthier if I just lost my
last deal I need to make money then I'd
be looking at
uh charging more and making it more
Hands-On so not just like do the app and
I'll check in on you but like you're
doing the workouts with them you're
watching them you're giving them plan
you're an accountability partner
um okay going after the people who are
trying to compete not really I mean
that's that's such a small segment of
the world just more people that um
really had I mean you saw you've seen my
stuff before I was really heavy and
everything else more people are just
trying to get uh fixed their health
problems and not have the problems from
you know from having a little bit too
much uh body fat well the thing is like
the the people who are competing you
could charge more for because it's more
Niche oh yes for sure so I would I would
be looking at that as like how do I get
somebody who I could charge a lot more
to
if I was going to help like if if I was
you right I went to zero I lost my last
client and whatever I'm not I'm not
growing uh I could help any entrepreneur
I could say hey I'm going to help you as
an entrepreneur or I could help you with
your YouTube channel
right okay specific if you're just going
to charge some executive to be a PT like
there's so many people who can do that
but if you're helping people get ready
for competition there's fewer people
doing it but fewer people who are
coaching as well so what I would try to
do is get in touch with all of the
people because you can do it globally
which is which is better right
who are the people who are organizing
the competitions who are the people who
have who maybe competed and lost
you know then you can reach out to and
say hey I'm a trainer who specializes in
this let's work at you right so the
direct decline I think you'll have a
much better result with that in terms of
clients than posting on tick tock okay
Outreach to build referrals again to get
you to the point where you're making a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
to feed you and everything else
right and then worry about content and
everything else because you're you're in
such a niche that people respect and
will pay for they just need to know you
exist okay okay so direct reach direct
Outreach to to uh the competitions and
any any sponsors or anybody related to
any of those competitions not the big
ones you're not training like Mr Olympia
but there's so many of the little ones
right right all of those the the the
people who are organizing them
as well as if if any of their websites
show their past
um
contestants
who didn't win right right right okay
okay I didn't win last year I want to
win this year or I came eighth last year
I want to at least get bronze
okay
that makes a lot of sense I like that
and then you could charge five times as
much to train that guy than Joe Blow
executive down the street
okay
what's the best part of helping
entrepreneurs we all want to help
somebody
so we all want to feel like we're making
something today that matters and means
something right
and I think I mean if we've talked about
a lot in the books the purpose comes
from your pain I just struggled so much
as an entrepreneur that I want to help
other entrepreneurs so it doesn't mean
that everybody has to go help
entrepreneurs but whatever you struggle
the most with is what you want to help
other people through so every time I
help an entrepreneur it's a reminder
back to 19 year old Evan who was
struggling to get his business off the
ground and making the 300 bucks a month
and uh it feels like 19 year old Evan is
is happy especially when you can start
to see people get traction and get
results and knowing that that's because
of you your spark that one thing that
you did and told them
um that's I think that's what we're all
after whether we're helping
entrepreneurs or or others real in here
you know I gave him a killer strategy
but but he did it you know I spent 20
minutes with him cool but he he went off
and started to apply it and that's the
best part is when you help somebody and
and then you get to see the results of
it when they come back a month later a
year later whatever it is and you say
hey like my life changed because of you
is I think what we're all trying to
create it's it's the best whether we're
helping entrepreneurs
um or others I'm here to change the
world let's go so what contribution can
I be how do you want to do it what do
you want to create who do you want to
help I'm a therapist journalist reporter
I do body work coaching uh all sorts of
things
two and a half years ago I'm one of the
miracle survivors of the Beirut
explosion I lost everything 49 years of
everything so it took a lot of work but
I saw 2022 coming and I said I have to
come back
for the globe I know we are more than
just this flesh and blood
and I'm here not just for this country I
did my healing work here I had
completely forgotten that I exist in the
equation when I was helping people for
the past two years
uh but something interesting happened
before that their medicine Crisis began
so I started asking a question
what is right about this crisis and what
can I do how can I change it and I
started going back to
um modalities I used to do before uh
because we all know the cliche therapy
never works doesn't work anymore I found
myself to you and something called World
Council for health
a bunch of crazy doctors we are only 600
people now
but creating massive change so
um
I'm here to inspire that Miracles exist
that me we are more than flesh and blood
and make money now because I did it for
free for two years three years
and this year I'm starting to charge the
momentum is so I'm so ready to just
launch you know like a rocket thanks for
coming on and sharing your story and I
the The Next Step becomes okay well
you're gonna start charging but what are
you charging for are you charging for
speaking okay I no I do
um touch therapy
uh for trauma for Recovery 95 of
everything is based on stress and we all
know now
all the drug companies everything is
scrambling soon
so
I do natural techniques one of them is
access bars other thing EFT tapping uh
something called No Hands massage Body
Work DBT CBT psychotherapies and all of
it where do you where do you live now
are you back in Beirut
okay and so that is something that has
to be local right like you're yes it's
slow I'm working here this is my massage
table here okay are you just uh the
business are you do you want to create
yeah around it
Consciousness we are here to I'm here to
just raise Consciousness and so far 500
people here chose this modality and
they're showing up slowly
so the more I'm showing up also
others are coming
so
with a service-based business like
you've got
the main thing to get the business off
the ground is referrals
referrals in two ways the first is okay
current clients
so clients come back
like around two and they come back for
round three they come back yes you even
sell for anybody who's got a
service-based business sell packages
imagine somebody working with you for a
year what does that look like
so what does that look like you know
financially what does that cost to come
well oh this is where this is a problem
Lebanon is the worst financial crisis
since three years the world has seen
since the
1850s well here's the thing though there
are 30 people who can pay you
yeah
buddy like there's a difference between
at the beginning of a business you need
to figure out how can I start making
money in doing the work that I love
doing and and you can have a big impact
and and want to change the world I love
it yes and that'll come through content
and workshops and and books and seminars
and all of this stuff but if you don't
have a business to support
your life and team then none of that big
stuff happens so the easiest first path
is you create a business that can
service you don't need that many clients
you know you need no I don't you need 20
right who are paying you consistently to
build a great business for yourself and
no matter what climate like Beirut may
not be as good a place as Las Vegas but
you don't need all of Beirut I know what
you're saying yeah 30 people yeah right
and the worst economic climate there are
still 30 people who have enough money to
pay you for the things that's absolutely
true so that's that's what we're
focusing on at the beginning focus is my
business for now then which is great and
and so what does an annual program look
like so to work with you for one year
what does it cost and trying to turn
a one-off massage session or touch
therapy session into a program because
they need it ongoing right like you can
come in there exactly make them feel
great but then they're going back to
their life and stress and problems and
Trauma and all of this yeah
this is it my biggest challenge is to
show people how beautiful and how
magical and how potent they are so
that's another
challenge but the the biggest challenge
is then thinking okay when you have
somebody who comes in how do we get them
to your thing is hard to talk about they
need to experience it but once they
experience it they're going to feel
better they come out they come in a
person they leave a different person
they've been changed in the work that
you do so cool but a one-off experience
is not enough no it's not gotta be
certain things but come in and you can
say Okay that was a great first session
we have packages there's a quarterly
package as an annual package and so if
somebody come to you once a week or once
a month for a year how much does that
cost and you give them packages
from the first time that they come and
see you so we start making money
especially if you can sell a package for
a whole year and they pay up front
that's great that's great for you right
now we start solving our own cash flow
issues
um and the more that you provide a great
service the more people will come back
and the more they'll tell their friends
the second part of doing referrals is
other other people in the medical
community this community it's already
happening
but expanding your network in the
medical community letting them know what
you do and uh building those networks
they start passing you more and more and
more business
you can then grow and I don't know what
the numbers look like in Beirut you know
in in America
you can then build a three four five
hundred thousand dollar business just
off of that
by years by yourself doing it maybe an
assistant or whatever to help you book
people in
um and that starts to fill up all your
time
what ends up that's like that's step one
so sell sell packages get repeat
customers coming back and build a
referral network of other professionals
who are going to pass business on to us
that gives us you know a a very good
solo business right again I don't do
equivalent but like three four five
hundred thousand dollars you can do that
in the in America uh after that the
problem becomes
you're trading all your time for money
and you're not having a big impact
you're just helping 30 40 people who are
coming in regular sessions and then you
have a growth
uh opportunity where is it do you start
you can either charge more for people
you can either have people who you train
in your modality and your training
people how to do what you do and and
having it as a licensors or franchisees
and then there's people you have 500
people around the world doing this and
you're teaching them your style
um or you go down the path of content
creator where you're making YouTube
videos and you're making you're doing
speeches and you're doing books and all
that so the world you know starts to
become open to you
once you start making enough money that
you're not worried about money
so Step One is build a referral Network
sell packages build our business so that
we have our 20 30 clients who are paying
us regularly and take care of all of our
immediate financial pressures
then once you get to the point where you
feel like you can't grow anymore you're
just trading all your time for money we
start looking at scaling opportunities
excellent because I yeah I will start
teaching also so perfect the challenge
in doing all of that at the beginning is
in like nothing yeah of course yeah and
you're not making enough money so yeah
so that path to like being the
practitioner first
go sell those packages go build that
referral Network yeah it's funny and one
week I made more than I made last year
so
what else is possible with this yeah
that's amazing yeah and congratulations
Faith had the winning topic today about
getting a new program launched tell us
quickly what are you trying to launch so
we can Workshop a little bit more I
teach Tai Chi and Qigong I have for a
long time in person and I'm putting
together an online
School Academy
Community
to to teach and you know to serve right
I've spent my whole life studying this
and it's like it's time so I'm getting
that together
it's ready I have a plan but then it's
like I think about social media right
and I'm also a photographer so my social
media you know like I post flowers and
stuff
um and so also to put that topic into
something I can start to share and put
forth to people maybe in my personal but
in my community group and and really
it's just like getting started like
where do I start to tell people like hey
this is happening
come join me
who do we want to be in our community is
it is it people who want to learn Tai
Chi people want to teach Tai Chi like
who are the ideal people for this people
who want to learn and practice Tai Chi
got it and and it's a course or it's a
membership it's meeting with you once a
week or month or what what do I get if I
join I'm going to have
a couple of different options I'm going
to have live Zoom classes
that will meet weekly okay
um recordings will be available to those
students after so I want to have like
that place they can go and have their
references I'm also going to do some
recording classes so people can have
that option if they just want to do
recordings and then Community is such a
big thing that I'm going to also have a
community site where the students can
interact with each other and get support
I know you know I I'm not a Tai Chi
practitioner my sister was Hardcore into
it
um how much of it is practice versus
learning like I mean at the beginning
there's a lot of learning techniques and
the movements and breaking it down how
much of it is
if I'm an intermediate student now how
much of it is like do I get bored in the
beginner class or is it kind of it's
still helpful uh it is Progressive
learning
so as a student goes through the program
the the courses continue so practice is
a big part of it because Tai Chi is a
practice
and it's one of the things that
I want to address because if you just go
to class it's not a follow-along kind of
a situation right like I really want
people to embody it and take it home and
do it right but the there'll be an intro
class that will be alive but eventually
that intro is going to go more into a
recording with Live Support
sort of like what we're doing here
because as people go once they go
through the intro they're ready for the
next course and they're ready for the
next course
but they can't start up here because it
really doesn't make any sense you know
they have to have the building blocks
that's part of the challenge yeah well
there's I mean so you know with every
challenge is an opportunity and um I
just came back from Vegas met Zayn there
I was speaking an event with garyvee and
a bunch of people and uh on my flight
back I was there early because you never
know like get to Canada if there's going
to be delays or whatever and and I got
stopped in the um the airport lounge
he's like Evan I saw you speak at the
thing can I ask you a question so hey
grab a seat and we chatted for 20
minutes before she went to her plane and
she taught it's similar so she taught
guitar
so it's guitar classes not that you know
guitar is Tai Chi but close you know
we're learning we're teaching something
and it's the same component of like
Community plus learning the challenge
that she faces that you'll face that
other people will face along this
journey is there's there's a certain
level of knowledge that people need to
be able to do to be able to practice it
like if you're just starting to teach me
like I don't know where to put my hands
why where do I put my legs what am I
doing right like very basic stuff for
people to figure out
uh which once you learn those basic
things you kind of don't want to do it
again you know it's like it's kind of
boring to go back and do it again except
for the I come from the salsa dancing
world and like to say like the beginners
want to learn the intermediate stuff the
intermediates when I learned advanced
stuff and advanced people go back to the
beginning
right like to really refine because you
think you got the hand motion but you
don't even know what you're doing with
it so that's like super high level but
most time like the intermediates don't
want to hang out with the beginners
they'll help but it's not valuable for
them as much to learn anymore so usually
the the best way to do it is to split it
where the first part is a course
so the foundation of Tai Chi and teach
me how to do the basic motions so that
or movements or whatever whatever it's
called
um so that I'm ready to go to
the group practice
so there's there's it's either a course
or like a boot camp where you're doing
it live with them but there's a start
and an end and it's a fixed State it's
like I will teach you how to do tai chi
inside of eight weeks or or whatever 20
weeks 16 weeks four weeks however long
it takes you to do it right but you have
people start together or it's a course
where it's Evergreen and they're
following along so that when they get to
the community side of things if it's a
weekly practice that you're doing like
hey join me every day at 9am Pacific or
whatever and we're gonna go do tai chi
together it's less instruction of how to
do it and more just community of us
doing it together
does that make sense
um and then on top of that you could
sell more private one-on-one of like how
do I how do I really master
that move or how do I use Tai Chi with
my hip that's hurting me or how it's
like all sorts of different custom
things that people then ask like you
know they want to go deeper and so
that's when you sell the one-on-one at a
higher level so there's there's course
or boot camp at the beginning
it's just basically planning for the
fact that the beginners will get to the
intermediates and the intermediates will
start to get bored and so they're not
all mixed into the same group
right so Boot Camp or or workshops or or
course
teach it in eight weeks then it goes to
the community side where and they paying
like less teaching but just more
community in every it could also be
people who you have who lead this it's
not always you who has to lead it it
could be a daily thing every day like as
you build and scale and grow every day
there's a new there's a new Tai Chi
Community thing to do it together like
in our Park here people go and do tai
chi every morning and it's a community
thing where they run through the same
sequence together even if they haven't
met each other
right like if I my sister could go and
meet other people I've never met before
and they just they know how to do the
same motions in the park together
um so now I don't have to practice by
myself now I've got this Zoom Community
people to do it
uh and then you're the you're you're the
top are you the queen or you're the head
um and if people want more one-on-one
access then that's what they go to you
for
how does that set
yes that that sits great and actually
lines up with what I was thinking in
terms of bringing people in and the
progression because you can't yeah
you've got to progress them and you
can't mix them and that's that's sort of
always the challenge so
one question related to that right is we
talk about social media and it can apply
for anything that we're putting forth
right and like posting and you know
content and all of that
do you have any suggestion on how to you
know like do you just put little quotes
or like like I don't really know how to
do the social media part and start to to
propagate that to you know kind of bring
people into the
whole thing
yeah so okay let me let me pull up your
account and then we can we can we can
dissect it together here get some
feedback so is this it this is the one
uh no that's my Instagram photography
thing that I don't really do anything
with I have I don't have a handle on
Instagram oh okay cool well well so
anyway but you know what this is a good
indication of like what I normally do
cool but that's not that's that's next
right so you know your founder of your
school awesome says Tai cheek you got
cool awesome
um whether you want to update this one
to become the brand or we're going to
launch a new one for the brand in terms
of making content everything can work I
mean we're seeing the biggest success
right now with reels I talked about that
mover makers a few times but reels are
performing just insanely well super
short clips
um and obviously we need to talk about
Tai Chi we need I mean it's great to
have flowers and stuff but we need to
talk about tai chi on our on our Tai Chi
camp that people know that they can get
access to you and what you're up to and
the value of Tai Chi and what is we're
targeting beginners like what is Tai Chi
how can it help you how has that helped
you know you personally how has it
helped the students in your class not as
a sales pitch but but value-add and a
good indication of type of content to
make is look at the people who you're
following
so let's see who you're following so if
I click on who you're following Evan
Carmichael okay good follow I follow
personal development coaches only and a
few photographers on my Instagram nope
but that's good like if you look at
these people
you you take like you follow them for a
reason they make you feel some they make
you feel a certain way you know you love
their message you know you're following
Tom and Jamie and Mel and and other Mel
and Anthony and I mean these are all my
friends this is great
um
so what is a what is it about then that
makes you
want to follow them and whose content
are you like most engaged with and and
your job was to take and capture some of
that feeling but put it inside the world
of Tai Chi
so your message isn't that off from a
Mel Robbins or Jamie Kern Lima just the
packaging is through Tai Chi instead of
a speech
does that make sense
yes am I am I am I too out there like
talking not at all and and really when I
when I look at you know what they're
putting forth right it's yeah it's good
I mean my Instagram it's sort of like
when I scroll it it's sort of like a
personal development 101. but
um and that's fine and that's what you
do
like Tai Chi is Person of element it is
yes it's just not through speeches it's
through motion right right like people
people leave
my side of my sister like to come out
more confident more more self-aware more
um more self-belief more connected like
all all of the benefits that you get
from personal development just you're
teaching it through motion as opposed to
you getting on stage and
and speaking or writing the book
personal development in Tai Chi are not
like
two totally separate entities you're
you're accomplishing the same thing just
through different different ways so
that's the point like if you think of
who you love about personal development
and and then take that part and throw it
into Tai Chi
so we're talking about how to or we're
showing how to have more belief or
self-awareness to self-respect through
the motion of Tai Chi I mean I wouldn't
stress out too much about having the
Perfect Picture Perfect video or
anything yet
um just get started because you don't
have you haven't started on that new
account yet or transition your account
um but yeah if you can mix that like
personal development that you love mix
it with Tai Chi and that gives birth to
you know the content that's how you
start to post content that's going to
win
okay that's really helpful thank you
thank you
thank you it's a weird thing to say that
personal development is Tai Chi you know
like that like they're we're both
getting into this but it is it is no it
is you're right I love that so you gotta
capture the essence of personal
development and mix it with Tai Chi and
now we've got special Faith brand that
nobody else can can match awesome thank
you for that thank you so much
I came back to the the community after
um basically from covid joining a firm
um but kind of going through these
iterations of doing everything that you
inspire and advise me to do but
unfortunately the environment's a little
uh super intense and very stressful and
kind of toxic but I keep putting my head
down to pursue it at the goal of being
uh of being a partner so at the end of
last year because the projections didn't
come true uh based on what I was brought
under the Compensation Plan
um basically I was incentivized that
there would be a partnership agreement
this year
um and so Tuesday we went to lunch
finally after monthly talks with the CEO
from July to now and uh did not come out
what was I expecting and what I was
enticed for this whole time and so now
I'm trying to keep my head down and stay
focused and keep the positive North
light but I feel very Rocky in my career
career again versus having this goal of
growing with people and having a bigger
impact than doing everything on my own
and so the question is
how to figure that out so I've had a
couple talks with mentors around this
and I know talked about Zan and some of
the others in the community and it's
about building a brand Do Your Own Thing
what I realized for myself is I'm a very
extroverted person I'm complimented
better when I'm in a component of a team
versus being a solopreneur
um I'm you know I'm good at strategy put
it you know impacting others or
communicating marketing
Investments and like wealth building but
now it's to figure out
where do I go to have that larger impact
and do what you said which is have that
North Star that continues to be that and
I think one of the challenges from covet
is I had ownership of my trajectory is
part of a business for our partners and
businesses now I don't have ownership
over my income and financial funds and
trajectory and that's been constraining
me because I'm not doing as well as I
was prior to covet
sure I mean you just don't have
ownership of your trajectory inside this
company
but you still have ownership of your
trajectory for where you could go
correct and that's and that is a
important mental distinction for you as
well that it's not over and you're not
screwed for life and you're not
permanently stuck and it doesn't mean
you have to go quit this job right now
and go without a parachute you know into
the Brave New World you know you don't
want to start a company at least not yet
awesome and what's great is you know
kind of what you want to do like having
that North Star you don't you don't need
to be stuck on the how
you know you want to have a bigger
impact you know you want to have
ownership you know you want to serve
more you know you want to work with a
team you know you want to have a boss
that supports you mentors you guides you
and and values you great
how all that happens you don't have to
you like you'll never figure out those
steps from where you are right now
and that's okay why is that because the
way that my brain is wired is to think
about the Tactical and I hear you say
that all the time but I don't understand
it because I think about reverse
engineering yeah and there's nothing
wrong and listen I'm the same way like
gold oriented what's the plan how how
how let's go
I love that that's the best the problem
is there's too many variables that you
don't understand
so your plan right now is based off of
what you currently know and you don't
know enough so your plan has a million
holes in it
so it doesn't mean don't have a plan
but recognize that your plan is very
basic compared to what you're going to
make
and this is why there's a problem or at
least I have a problem I think with five
or ten year goals
because you just don't know like go back
to meet from 10 years ago whatever plan
like you've been goal-oriented and plan
oriented you know most of your adult
life probably so if you go back look at
you from five years ago or ten years ago
you know samit in in 2015 making his
plan for 2022 you're not here
because 2015 samit has just different
information
he doesn't know what he knows now
and so there's a it's an audacity to
then think well I can I know where I'm
going to be in the next five years or
seven years or what my plan is going to
be so you make your best guess at a plan
like don't let that be so overwhelming
that you do nothing because that's the
worst okay your your plan is to
start talking to a lot of people until
you create an opportunity
do you think there's any uh necessary
steps I think this was the so I was in
in the Big Four County in New York City
and I've tried to stay within the
umbrella of real estate but I realize I
don't need to always stay to that but do
you think that there's unnecessary focus
of staying in a in a I don't know it's a
Continuum of your skill set development
so that you're not jumping from one
thing for two to three years and then
another thing for another two three
years I I think about it as momentum but
I think that's also what prevents me
from going to other areas yeah similar
to this like the very first question
that's a hard question
you're trying to answer a heart question
with your head yeah the head would be
yeah staying the same thing get more
experience go keep learning get better
improve build more contact stay in real
estate that's logically what you should
do yeah the problem is if your heart's
not into it you're not going to win so
if you're going to be going off and
learning some new skill because that's
what's in your heart to go off and do it
may it may be it may feel like a step
back but it ends up creating a thousand
steps forward
because if you just stay in real estate
what you're going to do if it's not at
you in your heart you're going to learn
to hate it more and more and more and
more and more every day
and it's the right strategy head wise
for who you are right now and what you
know but it's not what you actually want
to become now it doesn't mean you go off
and dump it all and become a vegan Chef
I don't know or maybe it is
you know that's your thing but you have
a it'll be a temporary setback as you go
and learn that thing and it doesn't
sound like you're like an all-in kind of
guy you want to make your steps to make
progress so I would explore I think the
best thing you can do right now is you
have your intention which is awesome
now you go explore
you go explore you start talking to
people you start talking to mentors you
start asking questions you do the
Outreach from people in your industry
and say hey I'm I'm uh I'm a young
professional in this industry I'd love
to pick your brain for 20 minutes I'm
stuck in that kind of career choice
right now
and whatever kind of personal connection
you can make whether it's at the company
maybe there's an alumni from the same
University that you went to maybe it's a
friend of a friend of a friend to line
up as many sessions with with potential
mentors as possible and something good
will happen
um very helpful I think that happened to
me like so when I sold my business I
didn't know what I wanted to do it was
great I had money awesome but I didn't
know what I wanted to do next and I said
yes to a whole bunch of things and one
of them was a guy who was in Venture
Capital who's part of a firm and I was
curious about raising money didn't I
didn't know how to do it because I never
had to
and he brought me under his wing and I I
joined the Venture Capital firm for a
year and a half
learned about all sorts of different
Industries and and that wasn't my
forever thing that was my next thing
that then led to this
and I've been doing this I've been
helping entrepreneurs for wow I don't
know how many years YouTube alone has
just been 12 years
um but that being said like if you if I
stopped liking videos
I would I would just walk away from
YouTube
next
because you'll never win doing work that
you hate I've done that like my website
was the thing that was making me a lot
of money I used to have a what I mean my
website was off my name we had a hundred
something thousand pages of content
making money every day from advertising
and Partnerships and brand deals and all
that stuff and it'd start to feel more
like a job
and um I just didn't like it and I was
really enjoying video making YouTube so
I overnight
shut down my website
put up a picture
to say you know working on it coming
soon
and now you can't find any of that old
content
on the site
and for me it's a much more Vibe thing
like Logitech doesn't make any sense
but it ended up it works out because it
when you follow your heart great things
happen now I'm here if I stuck doing the
website I would hate my life
I I appreciate that I don't want to take
up too much time so um very helpful I
think I am much more logic driven when I
look at like evaluation so try I I have
a lot of heart but I tend to make these
type of bigger decisions with logic so
trying to even though you say failure
it's a little bit challenging for me to
make that switch it's the only thing
that matters though for this
like this is the this is the ultimate
skill to learn
for big decisions like this it doesn't
mean like the concern then becomes well
we get too emotional and then I just do
whatever comes into my head and with a
little no you're not you're never going
to be that guy you're never going to be
Reckless
yeah but for big imagine if you're
getting married
you better love her
as opposed to well logically you know
like it makes sense
I think it's probably both of those
right but it better be a lot of low
expectations
[Laughter]
better be a lot more on the love
on the logic
yeah like you see a lot of the guys who
have been married for a while like oh my
gosh I hope he gets this like I'm not
married yet so that's one of the reasons
like this is this isn't this is a skill
set to start to trust your heart which
you need you need both
there are some people who only listen to
the heart and are like doing all sorts
of crazy things and never say consistent
on anything and and never listen to the
head and never stay focused never gets
that's not you you're the opposite yeah
so you need you need to tap into heart
more and it'll make you a more
successful
business person human how you don't like
to focus on how do you tap into the
heart is like I guess the last question
when you feel
something come through you
when you get an idea
your next step is when you get an idea
go do something on it
yeah two percent rule two percent
difference right so when you get an idea
what you will do is automatically start
to plan it and judge it and come up with
everyone's holding up the special
Cleveland Edition
I got that copy as well 2019 tour let's
go yeah that's it like when you get an
idea do something on it and and the good
news is it's all low risk like what
what's your next
idea but to to train yourself that great
ideas flow through you and to take some
immediate action on it this is what I
did because I'm much more logical and
strategic
I I was like you and I had to train
myself to do more heart
first
big decisions with your heart because if
you go into your next career or your
next relationship just doing logic first
you're always going to be unhappy
I appreciate it thank you Evan I'll I'll
report back on how that goes full man
keep us posted Chris in the house what
do we got man so I'm looking at like
this whole like the Fast Five part
um
and start reaching out to people
um the amazing content 10 pack
everything else I guess my question is
for the kind of search that I would be
looking for
um you know I'm looking for the 40 plus
mail that is dealing with
um the quote-unquote dad bod issue and
stuff like that and wanting to get
himself in a better shape uh
and then I'm almost probably gonna look
at Instagram because even uh even though
us um people in our later 20s like
myself still go to Facebook uh the I
think most of the people that are
looking for Fitness are on Instagram
everyone about politics on
Facebook I don't got time for that so go
to Instagram to do that right uh what I
mean what kind of search would I use
because it's like my fear would be I
would cold message a guy and say hey
look you know I was just like I felt
your pain trust me uh you know I was 267
270 some odd pounds two blood pressure
pills I was at I was where you were at
uh these are the life changes I made I'd
love to help you I almost feel like I
might insult a guy going will you
calling me fat or something like that no
I'm calling I'm not calling out in any
of this I'm trying to help you
overcomes a challenge at your face cool
yeah so great great question
um the concept from build to serve is
the fast passive Freedom where you're
creating a little bit of content for
your page and then it's mostly based on
Outreach messaging people to offer to
help and it's the fastest way to be able
to grow your business but it's one that
a lot of people don't like to use
because it risks rejection and people
ignoring you or uh not understanding you
and you know a lot of times people don't
like doing kind of the Outreach in the
sales
um for you I would actually look at two
options I would look at Instagram I
think is smart
um
yeah I think Instagram is going to be
your best bet
okay
um maybe Discord
but really just yeah I would start with
Instagram
uh for your demo and I would look at two
different sets of hashtags okay the
first would be
something where they're like something
like overweight
okay like whether where they're
acknowledging so you're not calling them
fat
right they're already self-acknowledging
like overweight dad
especially if you're targeting
apparently overweight might be too big
you can see how much content is coming
in but overweight men overweight dad
and see what they post and and
you'll have some people who are posting
because it's deeply personal to them
because they're struggling they're
frustrated and like why am I so
overweight and and I'm I'm fell back off
the train and like they're they're
sharing their life and they're pouring
their heart and looking for some kind of
support right that's somebody that
you're very empathetic to you're saying
hey I went through this too I'd love to
hop on a call and I've got a couple
strategies I think might work right so
the whole point is the Outreach is to
get them to then check your profile and
you look legit with what you've done and
hop on a call to talk to you about
strategies that then could lead to
coaching or whatever else you're trying
to sell right okay um so that's a much
more empathetic approach because they're
pouring a heart out and they're probably
going to get some comments and support
from their friends but nobody who can
actually help them where you could
actually help
um so yeah you can definitely position
it so that it's not
making fun of them because that's not
what's in your heart you'll also have
the people who are kind of making light
of it
okay right so whether they're using
hashtag overweight or overweight dads or
even that's where like Dad bod could be
one that you look at
where they're not they're not showing
how they are struggling with it they're
kind of leaning into the humor of it
okay saying look at me haha dad bod you
know like uh here was me at 20 now now
I'm but laughing at it and they're
they're using comedy as uh you know
they're struggling yeah they're just
using comedy right okay so for that
person when you're reaching out
you can say hey I saw your post on that
bot like you you lean in on the humor a
little bit more when you say but you
know what if you ever need help
and you want to lose a dad bod
I'd be happy to hop on a call and help
you okay okay unless like you're leaning
into the humor of it unless the empathy
because that's the spirit of the post
that they put up okay my second question
if I may is uh I I the guy that I work
with is my coach after I got certified
to become one has him and I have talked
about
um the conversations going on for a
while about becoming a coach under his
um umbrella but I know he's really busy
with everything he's got going on on his
own stuff so it might be a while before
him and I get to that point and I was
talking with Zan last week and and
there's even mentions in your book too
kind of like do the both hand like you
know you do you and also partner up with
other people my concern is that if I
start my own thing without even him
putting me under him it might ruin a
friendship and a possible business
relationship is there a way to to just
reach out to me go hey I'm thinking of
branching out at least starting to build
a clientele which will give me the job
experience plus I could work alongside
you but the things I've learned from him
I don't want to like sell off as my own
because well even if there's not a
copyright to it it's just dishonest do
you know what I'm saying yeah
honest conversation yeah okay
that's that's uh
is he in your city can you go see him
face to face or he's across the country
somewhere else he lives in North
Carolina and I'm in the sunny Tropical
Paradise of Cleveland Ohio
got it uh simite's happy with the
Cleveland
um yeah that that's a zoom call then
like video
that's not something you handle over
email okay and
what he needs to see is that you're like
he needs to feel your heart and so even
if you kind of stumble on the words and
what you're trying to say okay the fact
that you care about him and what
he has taught you and that you you're
not your intention is not to just steal
his stuff and go do your own thing okay
but you're also looking at like what
kind of relationship this is almost the
same as like you know to me when we
started this conversation up he wants he
wants something more than what he's
getting okay at his at his company and
so in sumi's case it was a no it was
like no we can't do that okay so
ultimately somebody needs to leave and
go find something else you know for him
to be happy like if you see if he's
still in the same spot in five years
that's a problem you know five months
okay you know as long as we're making
progress with five years is a problem
for you maybe if there's something new
that could be created like maybe he sees
a bigger spark in you that could lead to
a unique kind of relationship that
you're not just fitting into his typical
mold of what everybody else would be as
a trainer right maybe he wants you to go
and help train his trainers or create
some new division or like you never know
until you bring it up okay
so and I think that has to be done
ideally face to face but again you know
if you're not flying over there but but
Zoom at least so you can see you and and
feel your heart and your even again you
stumble over the words but he
understands better than like just a
well-crafted perfect email that's a
little heartless that could be taken the
wrong way because you inject your own
tone sometimes in a text or an email
that wasn't there from the author yeah I
mean if it's a big deal it may even be
worth flying over there
right I mean how much is a flight to
wherever like it's only eight hour drive
I can drive out there but sure like it's
it's the
um there's two things there it's like
the extra benefit of spending the time
face to face with them but also the
amount of effort that you put in to make
that happen
also speaks about like I really value
this that I would drive eight hours to
come and and see you
right shows how much you actually care
about this and it's not just a throwaway
conversation
coaching
you know
sounds good thank you
I have two questions I'll put them
together but one of them about Instagram
like I've never used Instagram as a
platform to grow on I was never
interested in growing on Instagram but I
use it as kind of like a resume so that
when people say oh where can I find you
like what can I kind of like you know
like think I'm like oh here's my
Instagram and they could kind of like
see like hey I'm alive I'm active I'm
I'm in the space so I was curious on
your thoughts on that and then the last
thing that I really wanted to ask you is
that uh I'm in the process of promoting
a book that I that I just uh co-wrote
I'm a collabor and off collaborate and
author and some of the best videos that
I found so far on YouTube on how to
promote a book are from Evan Carmichael
six and seven years ago
any uh thoughts that you had present day
if you were putting out you know I know
you just put out this book two years ago
which is still bringing us a tremendous
value in community and so many things
but if you were putting out a book today
or next month or next quarter uh what
would be some of your I mean I obviously
you have a huge following right so let's
say for someone like me that doesn't
have that well so it's taking both your
questions together you're you're trying
to accomplish two different things and
so if you want to sell a book then you
need to grow your following
it can't just be a resume
because you need to get people to you
want people to buy your book there's
nothing wrong with just having Instagram
as a resume cool that can that can
definitely work but like what are your
goals for where we want so my goal is to
tell the book cool now well we need to
have an audience
so when you're thinking about something
like a book or product or a course
launch or
um any of these things that we're trying
to we're trying to sell as as experts
there's always your own audience and
then there's other people's audiences
your own audience is the best long-term
most sustainable thing that you can use
and build so you know hopefully there's
not just one book inside Jose Gonzalez
there's more books coming up and so the
more you have an audience the more you
can promote your book
for future ones that come out so now we
need to start building an audience and
so what is your message what is your
content
um that's not going to happen like
instantly right away but we need to
start gearing our minds towards sharing
your message with people so that they
love you and they end up wanting to
support you and also support themselves
by picking up your books Etc
um next more short term for your own
following you could DM everybody on
Instagram with a video asking for
support
so if I really really really really
really really really needed to sell Bill
to Surf like if that was my top priority
I would go through whoever followed me
now we've got you know a quarter million
people on Instagram but if it was 2 000
or 100 I would I would video DM
everybody
to say hey Faith thank you so much for
following me I want to let you know I've
got a new book it's called built to
serve I'd love your support if if I can
send you a link to check it out
hey lady Lexi thank you so much for
following me like one by one
hand-to-hand combat going off to tell
people what you've got and asking for
their support
and so the bigger audits you have
they're easier that is to do it's not
you know there's only so many you can do
in a day right it's like I couldn't do
that for everybody who follows me but if
I if I was getting started and I wanted
to get my book out or I was launching my
course or whatever that's what I would
do that's why Instagram becomes
important
um we were watching a video this morning
from the CEO of Instagram talking about
Instagram's growth is in direct
messaging and reels
it's not about the pictures it's about
the a lot of a lot happens in the direct
messaging and then in the reels for
Content so use it's my favorite platform
for direct messaging every morning I'm
walking outside and I'm sending videos
to people thanking them for different
things
so that's what I would do as a starting
point with your audience and but it
changes the mindset now it's not just
a resume
that whether it's Instagram or Tick Tock
or YouTube now you you need to build an
audience if you want to sell your books
and anything else
um and then phase two would be also who
else can you
who has an audience that might be
willing to put you on
so one of the biggest things authors
always do when they come up with a new
book is they go in other people's shows
whether it's an Instagram live whether
it's YouTube whether it's tick tock like
wherever they have their audience you
want to try to be a part of it and
hopefully you gain a little bit of
following from them as well so that's
not a sustainable as building up your
own following but whenever you're in
launch mode that's always the two things
like what do I have for my own audience
and and who's who are the other people
who's honest I can tap into to promote
my book
awesome thank you Max good to see you
again cool man I love it we got Tanya in
the house what do we got Tanya
yes hi Evan uh so my question is in
regards of when you are using different
platforms like
um you have your followers all spread
out how is there any way is there any
strategy I don't know to kind of like
direct them to the one that you want to
grow like when I have my personal
account and I have my business account
so in business we have Facebook we have
Tick Tock we have Instagram
uh yes and and we are creating YouTube
after I started moving movement makers I
realized that you know we were missing
that one
yeah then we should have had before but
yeah so we are developing that one so my
idea is kind of like mirror what you're
doing and make uh give uh give more
importance to YouTube and then Tick Tock
with which I think is great it's a great
platform I I I haven't paid attention as
much but I like it especially for my
audience and then Instagram but I have
you know I have audience like spread out
is there any way together
I would say
it's not a great strategy to bring it
all together
so you want to meet people where they're
at
some people love Tick Tock and they just
want to stay on Tick Tock so don't try
to get them to Instagram like Instagram
I don't want to use Instagram
some people love YouTube so meet them on
YouTube and if you want to have a big
message then like someone like for me I
want to solve the world's biggest
problem so I got to be I got to be where
the most people are
if you have a if you have a niche
business and it only caters to certain
people then you want to be where those
people are like Tony he was on Facebook
right it's like to say I need everybody
to get over to Facebook
right to do that is crazy because people
are they don't want to use Facebook
anymore
so you meet people where they're at and
help them with what they need help with
and so that might mean having maybe you
can't be on every platform yourself
right now that's okay like you have to
pick YouTube and and one other cool
um but I wouldn't the only thing I would
try to do is capture their email address
so that you have a way to communicate
with them
but I wouldn't try to consolidate them
because a lot of my audience doesn't
want to meet me on Tick Tock or
Instagram and so and and when you do it
doesn't convert very well like people
come from my take my Instagram to
YouTube they don't watch the videos for
very long
so I actually want them to stay on
Instagram or on Tick Tock or on YouTube
like stay on the platform unless it's
converting to a sale
they're going to hire you for something
or can burn into an email address where
they're gonna
give you their email in exchange for
some bonus that you're going to give
them
okay great beautiful of that
uh
all right we got we got two minutes
Maria what do we got let's do it
I don't know it might be too much but
we'll do what we can so I I keep
grappling with this for years I have a
niche problem where I have two separate
websites
and I get clients from both and I I so
I'm sort of since I joined movement
makers I I body confidence Solutions and
I know that
the underlying reason that I help people
have sustainable change is I deal with
trauma I deal with stress I deal with
all the stuff that keeps them
you know just recycling back into Old
behaviors and so I have another website
modern stress Solutions which I still
like I was just invited
um on Monday so may is um is mental
health awareness month and I was invited
to do a presentation to 270 construction
workers because the suicide is the
highest industry of suicide
it was so gratifying but the point is
that I like I love doing that kind of
stuff around Stress Management around
so like people that look at body
confidence solutions they think well
she's a health coach
I on my I mean I talk about
transformation from the inside out and I
go deeper in my videos about yeah living
in your body and having a more better
connection with your body but that
includes releasing stress trauma
so it feels a lot to have two separate
websites I do two separate newsletters
every week sort of crazy
and I don't know if there's a way to I
mean they they are both connected and
they and you know my story is that I
healed from multiple Eating Disorders
but the stress Solutions is really the
how
you know
so um I don't know I guess my question
is
um
do I like I even notice when I do my
lives on Instagram and people there's
some people that like they really want
to learn some of these techniques even
if they're not struggling with their
weight
so do I I mean do I just keep my Niche
like with you know Health around weight
food and or broaden it I mean I get more
gratification out of
well I guess at all all of it I guess as
long as I'm serving and helping people
to uncover the stuff that's keeping them
stuck that's the piece for me whether
it's weight addictive behavior or
you know depression or any of that
so I think I think it's something a lot
of entrepreneurs struggle with to The
Branding and how many Brands I have and
how many websites and how many accounts
it it it is very taxing to have multiple
accounts and multiple domain names and
multiple emails and multiple Instagrams
and multiple tick tocks it can be very
very demanding it's usually not worth it
um so you have a couple scenarios one
you you leave one that's just more on
autopilot that's there that you're not
actively we're not taking it down but
we're not really doing much with it
because if something comes in cool but
it's not really where we're putting our
Focus or two you combine them into one
and and the one brand is not
not a brand name like body confidence
Solutions the combination is Maria de
Puma
and so everything that I do I'm I'm a
different person to different people for
some people I'm the believe guy for some
people I'm the YouTube guy for some
people I'm the you know the author for
some people I'm the salsa dancer you
know I'll go salsa dancing you know
brought up my studio but some people
don't even know what my business is I'm
just the guy who owns the salsa studio
and it leads to different conversations
but inside everything is still believe
for me your teaching believe through the
books through the content through the
YouTube channel through salsa dancing
through everything is all that's the
Common Thread so that for me is easier
and my my brands have always been a
reflection of me when I first started my
website I did Evan carmichael.com as a
as just as a landing spot like no real
thought behind it and then as SEO became
a thing I wish I called it like why
didn't I call it Small Business
Solutions or something like why didn't
you put some keywords in there and then
I realized no it's actually better
that I kept it off my name because my
name could be whatever I want my name to
be
and so you might find yourself in
another field in a couple years that
still relates to stress and anxiety and
how to overcome those but maybe it's
something completely different that you
realize it's still the same
um so I'm I'm in general it's easier
to build it off of a personal brand as
opposed to a company name that kind of
locks you into a niche so those are your
your three options like one you run all
you run both together and kind of will
always feel stretched between the two
maybe bring on team and help but uh you
probably won't do either of them really
well
option two is you take one and you
really commit to it and the other one
you just leave on autopilot and when
stuff happens stuff happens cool but
like this is what I'm going to be known
for or option three is you just build
your personal brand and wherever Maria
wants to go that's what Maria ends up
creating and it gives you a lot more
flexibility to do the next thing so I
thought it was the worst decision like
if you go back and ask me when I was 23
years old
I thought building it off of Evan
Carmichael first off sounds super
egotistical and also was like this is
the stupidest thing I could have made
because nobody knows who I am but if I
called it Small Business Solutions or
something it makes more sense but that
ended up being the most genius thing
that I could have done
um and people will connect with your
brand your personal face and your
message more than a company logo
if you want to get a copy of
our next training with me to ask your
questions you can go get the book right
there next to me right there I'll see
you there I'll see you to get the book
it's a good one much love